(enchanting bell music)
- [Narrator] This is the Addra Gazelle.
This gorgeous gazelle is sadly
on the verge of extinction.
Once spread across the
Sahara desert it is now only
found in pockets of Chad, Mali, and Niger.
Addra's are considered the
largest type of gazelle
with very long legs.
They're built lean and slender
to survive the dessert heat.
They're tan and brown coats blend
with their native surroundings.
They travel in herds; together
they browse and graze
grass and leaves.
Their strength in numbers
is a survival tactic
as they count lions, leopards and cheetahs
as their predators.
In the last decade their
population has decreased
by over 80%.
Along with habitat destruction
poaching and overhunting
for horns and meat have
caused the Addra to become
critically endangered.
And some estimate their
numbers at less than 300
in the wild.
This is the Addra Gazelle.